Québec solidaire prévoit près de 38
milliards de nouvelles dépenses sur
quatre ans le parti entend financer ses
dépenses en haussant les impôts des plus
riches et des entreprises ayant
supprimant les versements au fond des
générations ça permettrait à QS
d'arriver à l'équilibre au cours des
trois des quatre prochaines années
Québec solidaire prélèverait également
15 milliards sur 4 ans en impôt
supplémentaire chez les personnes qui
font 90000 dollars et plus ou en tout
cas sur les revenus des passants 90 000
avec un impôt également sur les actifs
nets de plus d'un million et un impôt
sur les successions des patients un
million de dollars 17 milliards en
impôts taxes et redevance aux
entreprises une économie de 17 milliards
sur le fond des générations et 8
milliards avec la création de pharma
Québec on en parle ce soir avec Mathieu
perron Dufour qui est candidat de QS
dans all et qui est l'un des architectes
du cadre financier du Québec solidaire
bonsoir Monsieur perron Dufour bonsoir
vous êtes je remarque ça moi ça me saute
aux yeux tout de suite le seul parti à
promettre l'équilibre budgétaire
expliquez-nous pourquoi
on a voulu faire ça de manière
rigoureuse à Québec solidaire on s'est
dit il faut mettre les moyens
nécessaires pour s'attaquer au grand
chantier de notre époque les beaux
enjeux climatiques aux enjeux sociaux ça
c'est des enjeux importants mais
l'argent pose pas dans les arbres donc
on s'est dit il faut aller mobiliser les
ressources
les ressources nécessaires pour le faire
vous avez énuméré certaines des manières
dont on fait ça et voilà et on arrive à
un équilibre parce qu'on démontre que il
faut s'attaquer à ces choses-là mais
qu'on est capable au Québec on a les
moyens de le faire et à Québec solidaire
on a le courage de dire on va aller
chercher les moyens que ça prend pour
des générations parce que ne plus verser
d'argent dans le fond des générations
qui est là pour rembourser la dette à
long terme on a toujours dit que c'était
de l'équité intergénérationnelle est-ce
que vous demandez pas aux générations
futures dans le fond de payer vos
projets d'aujourd'hui
le fond des générations a été mis en
place il y a beaucoup d'années pour
stabiliser le ratio dette PIB ça a été
accompli le ratio de PIB au Québec est
tout à fait sous contrôle et malgré
d'ailleurs toutes les dépenses que vous
avez énumérées tout à l'heure et bien
avec Québec solidaire on n'a pas une
augmentation importante de la dette on
reste autour de 44 % à la fin du mandat
qui est bien en deçà du 45% un peu
statutaire qu'on s'était fixé comme
cible alors on se dit mais on n'a pas
besoin de mettre plus d'argent dans le
fond des générations ce stade si à notre
vie est-ce que les générations futures
ont besoin ce dont elles ont besoin
c'est d'investissement dans les enjeux
climatiques les enjeux environnementaux
puissent au plus vite parce que plus on
attend plus la facture va être salée
puis plus ça va être difficile pour ces
générations là mais le fond des
générations aide les prochaines
générations à soutenir la dette à payer
de la dette et vous vous augmentez la
dette non seulement vous coupez dans le
fond des générations mais vous augmentez
la dette pour les prochaines générations
parce que les autres parties baisse la
dette par rapport à l'économie vous
voulez l'augmenter la dette mais la
dette elle va augmenter un peu à 44%
mais pas de manière importante c'est pas
grave et quand la dette du québécoise
elle est tout à fait sous contrôle on
n'a pas du tout malgré l'ambition duquel
notre corps financier notre programme
notre plateforme fait preuve on n'est
pas parti dans une spirale
d'augmentation de la dette sans fin de
déficit a pu en finir justement un cadre
équilibré on n'a pas de déficit dans les
années à venir et en plus c'est d'être
là elle est sous contrôle elle va pas
augmenter de manière importante à 44%
nous on juge que c'est tout à fait
raisonnable vous le faites en augmentant
les impôts également vous avez présenté
il y a quelques jours l'impôt sur les
successions puis l'impôt sur les actifs
net ça a été présenté comme un impôt sur
les Ultra riches je pense que la
démonstration a été faite que les
régimes de retraite accumulés pour une
personne de 60 ans qui est relativement
bien gagné sa vie mais que jamais été
millionnaire dans sa vie puis qui
dépasse un million n'est pas un ultra
riche
pourquoi vous présenter ça comme étant
quelque chose où on va aller chercher de
l'argent au plus riche de la société
l'ensemble de ces mesures-là c'est
simplement pour faire en sorte que
chacun contribue sa part pose aux enjeux
qui sont les ceux de notre époque et la
peur qui peuvent contribuer et ces gros
plats peuvent contribuer un peu
davantage c'est pour ça que on les amène
à verser un peu plus d'argent mais quand
vous dites que c'est pas nécessairement
les Ultra riches évidemment on peut se
disputer sur la notion de qu'est-ce qui
est un riche un ultra riche et tout ça
quand même du 5% le plus fortuné dans la
population
passés là mais qu'est-ce qui est un
riche pour vous
à quel niveau on est riche
tout ça c'est comment dire subjectif
comme définition qu'est-ce qui est un
risque qu'est-ce qui est pas un riche
nous à Québec solidaire on saisit ce 5%
qui est le plus fortuné de la population
sur eux qui ont un million d'actifs je
rappelle pour un individu pour un ménage
mais pour un individu ils sont capables
de contribuer davantage et c'est pour ça
qu'on a mis en place ces outils fiscaux
là est-ce que 90000 dollars gagné 90000
dollars c'est d'être riche
90000 dollars c'est d'être dans le haut
de la distribution des revenus au Québec
en ce moment certainement et puis
l'augmentation sur le revenu elle est en
haut de 100 000 $ en fait et 100000
dollars on parle d'à peu près 8 % de la
population tout à fait plus levier 23 %
de la population les hausses les plus
importantes arrivent autour de 125 150
et tout ça puis là à 125 on est rendu à
5% de la population encore une fois là
on est en terme de revenus c'est pas
tout à fait les mêmes barèmes que les la
fortune de tout à l'heure et donc là
aussi on est dans un petit groupe de
gens qui sont en haut de la distribution
de revenus qui ont déjà le taux le plus
élevé quand on prend le taux canadien
puis le taux québécois en état 53%, puis
le 15 % de taxes la TVQ la TPS le Québec
est déjà l'endroit au Canada où les
pressions fiscales sont les plus élevées
vous voulez créer une pression
supplémentaire fiscalement
non juste que ces personnes-là sont tout
à fait aptes à contribuer davantage pour
les différents programmes qu'on a mis en
place il faut se rappeler que ces taux
là historiquement étaient encore plus
élevé si on remonte dans les années 60
dans les années 70 à des moments où
l'économie à la CB dans les années 60
les taux marginaux étaient beaucoup plus
élevés que ça et ça fonctionnait très
bien est-ce que vous allez pas vous
retrouver à faire payer une partie de la
population qui est probablement dans les
revenus les plus élevés mais qui sont
pas les Ultra riches alors que les
ultra-riches jointes de déplacer
facilement leurs revenus tout comme les
grandes entreprises également
on a un ensemble de mesures aussi pour
contrer l'évitement fiscal pour contrer
l'évasion fiscale on va certainement
s'attaquer à ça c'est un problème c'est
un problème en ce moment ces gens-là
attendent pas l'augmentation de taux
pour commencer à faire leur show c'est
que ça on va certainement s'y attaquer
mais on pense pas et on nous on nous
brandit souvent l'espèce de spectre de
l'exode de tous ces personnages et
lorsque il y a augmentation d'impôts il
y a pas exode c'est comment ça se
produit pas comme ça vous avez la
certitude de ça la confirmation de ça
qu'il y a pas d'exode où il y a pas de
déplacement des sommes la plupart des
mesures qu'on veut mettre en place
existent déjà ailleurs il y en a pas des
successions par exemple aux États-Unis
il y a pas une exode d'américain vers le
Québec où il y a pas d'impôt sur le
succession par exemple donc nous on fait
le pari que ça va se passer au Québec
comme ça c'est passé partout ailleurs ou
c'est mesures long étaient mises en
place et qui aura pas d'examen important
bon on manque de temps pour tout dire je
mentionne que beaucoup d'argent un
nouveau dans le Plan québécois
d'infrastructure pour le transport
collectif et un peu moins et pas du tout
même le troisième lien notamment et
certains autres projets on va y revenir
aussi dans le débat économique que nous
allons présenter la semaine prochaine je
vais vous revenir avec la date parce
qu'on n'a pas encore la date prévue pour
le débat économique Mathieu perron
Dufour merci d'avoir été merci à vous
monsieur pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI